hi mom it's your sister she's gay with  you you don't smell like roaches in your  nothing  who is this charlie oh sorry gotta go  Tonya metal mining here goes she's never  even seen him we're pretty sure that the  guy who talked to isn't real I saw  bridesmaids I will take a [ __ ] in his  dress please don't do that  best way to get over a man is to get up  under a new watch and learn there's a  bow on the back thank you sir some time  is up there Frank has been trying to  take you out for like three years go out  with him  you are dressing me with your eyes my  nipples are getting out show me  everything you see circumcised excuse me  we got that  Mama's Anika put me out this connection  is so Rican it  hello what mama you know it I'm sorry  what we not all know cell phone line I  can't hear you baby I can't mama  [Music]  you